the frigid ocean of the video game
subnautica below zero teams with
incredible life
from gigantic herbivores to vicious
carnivores
like the tropical seas of the game's
predecessor this environment feels truly
unique an undersea world of bewildering
landscapes detailed ecosystems and
surprising mysteries
many of the aliens in below zero were
created by alex reese one of the most
talented creature designers out there
and unlike the first game in below zero
dangers lurk both above and below the
water
so for this entry into the archive we'll
embark on one of our documentary style
expeditions charting biomes under the
waves and upon the ice
this two-part series will analyze the
biology behind these puzzling aliens and
investigate how they compare to life in
earth's oceans and although this
experience once again ranks among the
scariest i've had while doing field work
for the archive i'm determined to
document this alien world firsthand
so let's dive in together and explore
the freezing depths of sector zero
sector zero is a region of extremely low
temperatures where organisms of all
types have had to adapt to the cold
beginning on the ice floats above the
shallows a curious life form makes its
home in this region where land meets the
sea huddled together on a float is a
flock of waddling penguins penguins are
small predatory fauna which aren't the
most graceful on land when a penguin
dives underwater however the creature's
unique retractable tail allows them to
twist through the currents with
remarkable grace
despite their cute appearance penguins
are carnivores and their beaks open
horizontally revealing a rather alarming
set of teeth
in their body shape and general behavior
penguins show a high degree of
convergence with earth penguins with
both species adapting to an arctic
environment in similar ways
and on any ice float with penguins you
will also find panglings the juvenile
form of penguins who never stray far
from their parents even more than adults
infant panglings are extremely awkward
on land but what they might lack in
overall balance they make up for in
endless enthusiasm and while penguins
might possess the same somewhat alarming
fanged mouth they're remarkably docile
creatures perfectly content with being
gently lifted up
as nice as it is to briefly hold a baby
pangling however i don't want to disrupt
their natural routines
as we dive into the polar waters a
shallow surprisingly warm region awaits
just under the ice floats the landscape
of this coastal sea is dominated by
coral bridges great arches formed by
rapidly growing polyps that can exceed
600 feet or 200 meters in length
bioluminescent blue barnacles grow on
the coral's underside which ascan
suggests are actually separate species
taking advantage of the bridge's
structure but why would the coral
bridges grow into such strange arcing
shapes the answer lies in a phenomenon
known as thigmatropism a pattern of
growth observed in earth plants in
response to touch stimulus thigmatropism
is what allows vines to wrap around and
climb up holes and it's the likely
reason the great coral bridges always
grow from one rock to another
just beyond these coral bridges we
encounter an arctic peeper who watches
for predators with its massive yellow
eyes relatives of the common peeper in
the tropical seas arctic peeper's scales
have evolved a white hue for better
camouflage against the ice other
familiar herbivores also swim here like
the translucent bladder fish in the
vibrant hoop fish together these species
form an important base in the sector
zero food chain for the larger less
familiar creatures that lurk under the
ice
swimming northwards i've reached a
region known as the sparse arctic this
entire biome is situated under thick ice
shelves and receives a little direct
sunlight on the underside of these
icebergs hazardous ice formations known
as brinicles protrude like jagged fangs
highly unstable brinicles frequently
shatter and crash to the ocean floor yet
as for boating as the sparse arctic
seems some truly remarkable species
thrive here
this odd looking fellow is called a
brine wing with its rotund form and
beak-like mouth it gives the impression
of an ineffectual herbivore but the
brine wing is a powerful predator to
hunt it unleashes a rapid-fire torrent
of supercooled saline solution that
freezes in the water and can encase its
prey in ice
a scan suggests that the brine wing uses
a highly specialized bladder to produce
this super cool brine from the
surrounding salt water as unusual in
adaptation as this might seem the earth
archer fish can shoot down insects using
water jets launched from their
specialized mouths and are remarkably
accurate
other species in the sparse arctic have
very different survival strategies like
the enormous titan holefish a
slow-moving herbivore with a strange
hole in the center of its body the titan
whole fish is a relative of the tiny
guppy-sized tropical whole fish and is
so much larger than its cousin you can
actually swim through the hole at its
center
but what is the purpose of this hole a
scan suggests the gel-like interior is
lined with hundreds of eggs but
curiously the egg's dna doesn't match
that of the whole fish
the mystery of the eggs is revealed when
i spot a tiny life form swimming
alongside the whole fish
soon many others join in swarming like a
bee colony around a hive these are
symbiotes small predators that have
evolved to make their nests in the hole
of the titan whole fish and in turn
defend the whole fish at all cost and
even provide it with food this highly
cooperative lifestyle is an example of a
mutualistic partnership one of the few
on planet 4546b
as a result the titan whole fish has
evolved to be remarkably unintelligent
swimming forward on impulse fully
trusting the complex ecosystem that
supports its every need
just beyond the sparse arctic the bare
sand gives way to the teeming arctic
kelp forest
here creep vine plants sway in the polar
current casting light into the depths
with their bioluminescent seeds these
creep vine plants are close relatives of
the green variety which grow in the warm
waters of the tropics although the
chemical composition of the polar waters
has turned them a pale yellow among the
fronds familiar fish like the boomerang
flit between the leaves and some very
unfamiliar fish swim here also these
extremely bizarre life forms are called
spinner fish and have perhaps the most
peculiar method of swimming ever
conceived using three pairs of siphons
along the side of their body spinner
fish jet along like living water wheels
at a glance its bizarre body plan
somewhat resembles the larval form of an
ocean sunfish but ultimately the spinner
fish is one of a kind
speaking of one of a kind i soon spot an
incredible life form i'm just about to
scan it when it swims in and snatches
the scanner right from my hands
frustrated i give chase and find the
creature occasionally looks back and
waves the stolen scanner to mock me
thankfully i'm able to out maneuver it
and snatch my tool back
finishing the scan i discover this
creature might be annoying but it's
truly remarkable with both a developed
brain and finger like appendages for
object manipulation it's called a sea
monkey a nickname it shares with earth
brine shrimp unlike those sea monkeys
however the sea monkey of planet 4546b
seems about as intelligent as an actual
primate meaning it's the smartest life
form i've found in sector zero
given time the sea monkeys might have an
incredible future trajectory i just hope
they evolve to be less annoying
with the kelp forest thoroughly charted
it's time to regroup on the surface
sticking my head above the water however
i find the shallows are engulfed in a
dangerous polar storm looking around i
realized the penguin flock from earlier
might be in serious danger
upon arriving at their ice float however
i find the penguins unbothered by the
weather simply huddling for warmth and
waiting out the rain
truly penguins are intriguing creatures
with the sun thankfully returning it
occurs to me that there's still much i
have to learn about penguin flock
dynamics but i don't want to disrupt
them further with my presence
time for some innovation
i've devised an alternative less
conspicuous method of observation this
machine is my spy penguin and it will
hopefully be able to keep an eye on the
penguin flock with its hidden cameras
while i continue my expedition across
sector 0. i'm uncertain if the penguins
will be fooled into accepting this robot
as one of their own but the only way to
find out is to test it as
inconspicuously as i can i deploy the
robot
taking control via an auxiliary remote i
navigate the spy pangling into the midst
of the flock it's not a perfect disguise
but the penguins don't seem particularly
bothered by its presence either though
it's unlikely this robot is fooling them
it doesn't appear to disrupt their
natural behavior i'll leave the flock
under its watchful eye and head deeper
into the unknown regions
even further out to sea the mysterious
lily pad islands hang in the water
seemingly by miraculous means
these floating chunks of rock are held
up by giant lily pads an enormous type
of plant that defines this ecosystem
giant lily pads are indeed so large that
it's possible to stand on their leafy
tops without fear of sinking but it's
the bizarre life that swims in the lily
pad shadows that makes this region truly
unique
take for example the hilariously named
newt fish with its colorful markings and
innocent beak-like snout the newt fish
can easily pass as a herbivore but any
fish that makes that mistake is soon
swallowed whole
the newtfish's beak is in fact a
stretchy extendable lip lined with
barb-like teeth it uses to envelop prey
this kind of extendable mouth somewhat
resembles that of the sarcastic
fringehead of the pacific ocean
best to keep an eye out
but there are bigger predators here than
the newt fish the brute shark is an
aggressive predator that scours the
depths with its ghostly white eyes
with huge fangs and a massive bony jaw
they feed on just about anything they
can catch
like many earth sharks they prefer to
attack via ambush from above or below
the only good news is that while they're
deadly brute sharks aren't particularly
fast still if i don't keep my distance i
might be on the menu
closer to the surface i spot a
remarkably colorful life form swimming
nearer the edges of my vision blur and i
feel just a little dizzy
has the sky always been that color
everything feels floaty for a while
eventually the effect wears off and with
a clear head i understand what just
happened that life form known as a lily
paddler possesses the unique ability to
disorient would-be attackers with the
mesmerizing patterns on its colorful
appendages
it's an impressive defense and a vital
one for a creature like a lily paddler
which is otherwise quite vulnerable i
just wish it didn't make my head hurt
a shadow passes overhead just above me a
whale-sized leviathan opens its mouth to
a tremendous size and swallows an entire
school of fish in just a single gulp
this is a glow whale and while they're
highly effective at feeding on small
fish they're thankfully quite gentle
at almost 100 feet or 30 meters in
length they're the first leviathan class
organism i've encountered in sector zero
and a highly intelligent one
a scan of the glow whales indicate they
possess many organs that are capable of
bioluminescence
most notably around the corners of their
eyes and the ends of their horns
careful not to startle it i brush a glow
whale under its eye causing a faint glow
it's difficult to interpret whether this
is a random response or an attempt to
send a message
in any case the glow whale seems content
with my presence as i watch it rejoin
its pod i wish i could stay with this
spectacular life form for longer
but before the sun sets there's one last
region i need to chart
underneath layers of snow and ice there
are telltale signs that a permanent
landmass makes up a portion of sector
zero dry land is so scarce on this ocean
planet that it's impossible to guess
what sorts of life forms might live
farther inland
passing through a nero canyon i find
strange plant animal hybrids that seem
to be growing from the walls
these are thermal lilies organisms that
spend most of their time tracking the
sun and absorbing its energy but also
turn to track by movement as i pass a
scan suggests they aren't dangerous and
thanks to the thermal radiation they've
absorbed they're actually a welcome
source of heat in sector zero's frigid
interior
still it's unsettling the way they
follow me
beyond the canyon a snowy landscape far
too vast to traverse on foot awaits
luckily i have an alternate method of
transportation this is a snow fox a
hoverbike designed for land-based
expeditions zooming over the arctic
terrain i find it's got a bit of a kick
at these speeds i should be able to
chart this region fairly effectively
a short time later i spot a hairy
creature in the distance
the question is is it friendly
not friendly putting the snow fox in
reverse i discover the creature gives
chase with alarming speed after several
near misses i back away to a safe
distance
that quadrupedal predator was a snow
stalker and while it nearly sank its
claws into me i can't help but be
excited at the discovery of a
terrestrial land animal on planet 4546b
with its white fur and imposing bulk the
snow stalker has converged on a body
plan similar to earth polar bears
i'm curious about the lineage of this
land animal a brief analysis reveals
surprisingly that the snow stalker is
actually a distant relative of the fully
aquatic stalker i encountered in the
tropical region while these two species
diverged a long time ago there are still
some telltale signs of their relation in
the shape of their head and their dorsal
spines
a fascinating genetic ancestry
speaking of which a short way off from
the snow stalker i spot what appears to
be its cub playing in the snow
just a fraction of the size of its
parent this baby snow stalker is far
less aggressive than an adult
well
mostly
trekking onward i reach an ice sheet
marked by jagged towering ice formations
this region is known as the arctic
spires and it's home to a giant
a huge head bursts from below the ice
seconds later a massive serpentine
leviathan rises into the air and nearly
takes me out with a swipe from its
massive horn this terror of the frozen
planes is an ice worm at over 300 feet
or 90 meters long it's almost twice the
size of a reaper leviathan and by far
the largest creature i've seen in sector
zero its glowing horn is superheated
through an exothermic chemical reaction
allowing it to melt through the very ice
its prey is standing on
time to make a fast exit speeding away
on my snow fox i spot the snow stalker
and its cub from earlier fleeing beside
me
we barely make it to safety with
creatures like the ice worm around i
think i might put off doing more field
work till tomorrow
while the sun sets overhead i check in
to find my spy pangling has become a
veritable member of the flock and has
done an excellent job keeping an eye on
its feathered companions
together my penguin bought and i sit and
watch the gorgeous sector zero sunset
and with the night comes a final
surprise the sky is lit up by a dazzling
aurora similar to the aurora borealis in
the northern latitudes of earth on our
planet these northern lights are a
result of disturbances in the
magnetosphere caused by solar wind and
we can theorize that they have the same
origin on planet 4546b
it's a beautiful imposing display that
can make one feel a little isolated in
the universe but with my spy pangling
beside me i don't feel truly alone
a transmission interrupts my thoughts
it seems i'm picking up a mysterious
communication
but from where
and who or what is sending it out
i'll venture deeper into the depths in
part two of the biology of subnautica
below zero investigating the source of
the transmission and the larger more
extreme and often more dangerous life of
the deeper biomes
for now though our journey is at its end
if you like these alien designs you can
follow and support alex reese in the
links below
and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
you